Okay, so let's get right to it. Most of
you are probably here because you've
seen my videos on the computer file
channel, but on the off chance that you
haven't or you haven't seen them all or
you don't remember them all, I mean, the
first one was like 4 years ago, um, I
thought the first video should go
through the existing stuff, get
everybody up to speed, and also talk
about the various directions that this
channel could go next. So, while we're
going through the videos so far, be
thinking about what kind of things
you're interested in and what kind of
things you would want to see more of and
uh leave me comments so I can decide
what to do next. Also, uh everyone
should be subscribed to Computer File if
you're interested in this kind of thing.
Firstly, because it's a great channel.
Uh and secondly, because I plan to
continue making videos there in addition
to these ones.
Okay, so the first two videos I made
were about sort of machine learning uh
basics just concepts like optimization
and the idea that we can think of
intelligence as optimization. We can
think of intelligence systems as uh
systems which optimize a particular
function over a particular space. Uh the
second video is just explaining what's
meant by a space in this context. People
who are familiar with machine learning
stuff will know this, but if not, check
it out. I could make more machine
learning basics videos going through the
fundamentals of how some of the
algorithms work and some of the sort of
core concepts of the field, although I
feel as though those are probably fairly
well covered elsewhere, like on computer
file. But if people are interested in
seeing more of that kind of content from
me, let me know. Okay. Then the third
video, the holy grail of AI, is where
the ideas and the hair start to get
really interesting. Um, it's where we
start talking about the difference
between the type of AI that we have now
and the type of science fiction AI that
we think of sort of human level true AI.
And we talk about the concept of
generality, the idea of having a single
optimizing system which is able to
operate in a wide variety of different
domains rather than these narrow domain
specific intelligences that we have.
Now, from there we go on to the deadly
truth of AI. um where I start to talk
about super intelligence and the way
that a very powerful intelligence can be
very dangerous even giving a fairly
innocuous seeming goal like collecting
stamps. There are all kinds of areas we
could go into from that video. For
example, we know that just saying
collect as many stamps as you can is a
very bad function to give this type of
agent. But what type of function might
actually work? What might be safe? We
could also look at containment. If you
have an agent like the stamp collector,
is there any safer way to run it without
being completely confident that you've
chosen the right objective function for
it? So, the next video is AI
self-improvement,
which is about the possibility that an
artificial intelligence could improve
its own code. That really only touched
on the on the surface of that. There's a
lot we can talk about there in terms of
how likely this is, how possible this
is, um what the time scales might be for
it happening. All kinds of questions
there to look into if people are
interested. So then we have the uh
Asimoth's laws don't work video, which
you know, I feel like I was too unkind
to Asimoth in this video. Um I came
across a bit too dismissive, but I stand
by the content of the thing. Asoff's
laws don't work as a solution to this
problem. Never really did and were never
really meant to. The field has moved on
and they're not really relevant anymore.
So I don't really I don't want to make
more videos about that. The next
relevant video was the one titled AI
safety which was sort of a response to
Dr. Holden's video Dr. Holden at
Cambridge who has another video on
computer file which you also should
definitely watch. Uh that video touches
on a few different subjects. I think the
one that has the most potential to be
built on is the question of predicting
future technology and the various
problems associated with that. So if you
want to see more about the the
difficulties in predicting AI, we can
make more stuff about that. Right. The
next video was called AI's game playing
challenge which is mostly about go. We
made that video because at that time
Deep Mind's system Alph Go had just
beaten the world champion and uh that
video is about the general way that AI
go about solving these kinds of perfect
information board games and why go is so
difficult and why it was such a huge
challenge and such a huge achievement
for DeepMind. There was originally going
to be a follow-up video to that one
about how it actually works in some
detail, uh, which we never got around to
shooting, and there is a pretty good one
on computer file as well, but I can talk
more about that if people want more
insight into how AlphaGo works. And the
last two, um, general AI won't want you
to fix it and the stop button problem
kind of go together. They're about one
of the more concrete problems people are
working on right now in AI safety, which
is just if you have a system, a general
intelligence that you've given an
objective to, how do you design it in
such a way that it will accept being
shut down and modified? Because by
default, general intelligences are
incentivized to prevent themselves from
being modified, from having their
utility functions modified specifically.
We could go into more detail on that,
some of the other approaches people have
proposed, maybe go slightly more
technical than the computer file videos.
I also made some videos unrelated to
artificial intelligence. Like uh the
first one I made was actually about
public key cryptography. If you'd like
an intuitive understanding of how public
key cryptography works, how it allows
you to communicate privately with people
without first agreeing on a shared
secret to use as a key. Check that video
out. I can do more crypto stuff uh if
people are interested, but I think that
that's fairly well served elsewhere on
YouTube. But let me know in the
comments. There was also the Code Golf
video where I explained the concept of
the game of Code Golf and uh I gave a
very short program I wrote that made
music which looks like this. I can't
remember how many characters it is. 240
something I think. Anyway, it looks like
this and sounds like the background
music. It's been the background music
the whole time. Um, I never really fully
explained how that code works in detail.
Um, if you want a video on that, let me
know. Another thing I'm thinking of
doing is taking a current uh, research
paper and just going through it bit by
bit so that over a series of videos you
get hopefully as full an understanding
of it as you would from reading the
whole paper. There are a couple of
candidates. The foremost I think is
concrete problems in AI safety which is
often recommended as a good introductory
paper. So, if people would like to see
that, uh, leave a comment. I could do
stuff about the work I did as a PhD
student about artificial immune systems,
which is only tangentially related, but
I think it's really interesting. Or
completely unrelated stuff. I once made
a robot that deliberately blinds people
with a laser. I'm currently working on a
game that you play using only your
eyebrows.
I made this battle axe, which is also an
electric ukulele.
[Music]
Uh, maybe I should make a side channel
for this stuff. Anyway, where do we go
now? Let me know what you think in the
comments.
[Music]
Wee! Wee!